you can't have a birthday bash without a
lot of gifts so audience birthday
buddies of mine
every time you hear this sound
because i love that sound you're in for
some goodies because we're giving away
more than 100 000
worth of gifts today
it's our biggest giveaway ever
it's time for a
is giveaway beautiful gentleman straight
from the set of not only the longest
running game show in television history
it's also my favorite game show the
price is right seven doda
you're looking spiffy as always are you
excited to be revealing some of our
prizes i'm so happy to be here drew and
to help give away some of these what
looks like some amazing prizes so let's
do it
all right
well let's get started first up
everybody hold on to your hats because
it's oprah daily oprah insiders can
connect live with oprah during her
monthly live stream and have unlimited
access to oprahdaily.com a subscription
to oh quarterly and so much more and
everyone in our audience is getting a
free one-year membership
and next up kara loha is known for their
luxurious linens that are all made out
of bamboo which is totally earth
friendly and eco-minded and you're all
getting a hundred dollar gift card in
the audience
[Applause]
i love a giveaway this is so exciting
and in fact i want to talk to one of you
where's to neil miller
[Music]
we heard that you're getting married in
may i am
congratulations congratulations
for your birthday and as an early
wedding present you're getting a resort
bamboo queen betting suite set valued at
over 4
[Applause]
the bed 000. bamboo sheep and pillows
happy birthday and happy wedding
[Applause]
are you ready let's do it drew let's go
all right first up flower hair tools is
the new wet or dry styling iron this
just literally launched this week and
it's perfect for achieving that ultimate
birthday hairstyle and it just came out
and everyone in the audience is gonna
get one
also blue light glasses from my company
flower i wear i'm also making sure you
all get a pair of those as well yeah
um
are you guys like are you sick of
giveaways or do you want another one
all right well everyone needs some r and
r on their birthday right so this is an
impact therapy device from truemedic
which gives you your very own personal
massage and you
are all getting one
that's right um and where is kelly
styles in our audience
hi kelly
hi kelly how are you
i'm very good how are you guys um we
hear that you are a busy mom and teacher
and military wife is this correct all
true yes
wow you're amazing oh thank you and we
wanted to give you just a little r and r
and it is time to kick those feet up so
that you can sit in your massage chair
from true medic value to 3000.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and everyone is getting a 300 gift wow
[Applause]
we have another giveaway dagny dover i
love has an amazing selection of bags to
fit every lifestyle and guess what
you're all getting a 300 gift card
thank you so much devon and last but not
least where's dreon owens
um i heard a story about
that um you like depend on your bike to
get around um but i heard it's broken it
is broken oh
well we've got something even better for
you we're going to give you a customized
g3 scooter from fat scooters valued
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you